DAVID THORBURN: One of the
things I aim for in the course,
is to try to show students, in
ways as concrete and rich as I
can, what the authority,
or power, of movies
in a cultural moment might be.
And I try to give them
some examples of that.
In my first lecture, I
sometimes read to them
from a passage from James Agee's
novel, A Death in the Family.
In the very beginning
of the novel
he describes, beautifully,
an excursion between a father
and son, going to see a
Chaplin comedy in 1915
in some southern city.
And what he describes is
what a social occasion
it was, what a moment of bonding
it was for father and son,
what a cultural
moment it was more
broadly for the whole
of the population that
went into the theater
to laugh uproariously
at Charlie's shenanigans.
"And then the screen
was filled with a city,
and with a sidewalk of
a side street of a city,
and a long line of palms.
And there was Charlie.
Everyone laughed the minute
they saw him squattily walking,
with his toes out and his knees
apart, as if he were chafed.
Rufus's father laughed,
and Rufus laughed, too.
This time, Charlie
stole a whole bag."
This time.
What does that imply
about the audience?
An intimate familiarity
with the previous adventures
of this character, right?
An ongoing, routine connection.
"This time he caught a
sight of-- this time Charlie
stole a whole bag of eggs.
And when a cop came
along, he hid them
in the seat of his pants."
What it showed was the cultural
embeddedness of movies,
even in their earliest
days, in the society,
and in the life of individuals.
So, part of what I mean
by the power of movies,
and what I try to encourage
the students to see,
is something of this
anthropological energy,
as well as its artistic
power as a representation
of human experience.
That the way these kinds of
stories permeated the society
helped to shape America's--
Americans understanding
of their natures.
Of what the social
fabric was like.
Of what masculinity was.
Of what femininity was.
Of what families were.
Of what the relations
among the races were.
Of what American history was.
About what the founding
story of America is.
About what the central,
organizing values
of our culture are.
All of those things are
dramatized, either explicitly
or implicitly, in movies.
And because the
movies were so central
through the 20th
century, they were
one of the central ways in which
the belief system, the values,
of American society were
promulgated, dramatized,
rehearsed, and in some
ways, altered and changed.
A related matter that
connected again to film,
in part as an anthropological
or sociological phenomenon, not
simply an artistic one, as
a social practice in a way,
has to do with the
power and role of genre
in movies, which is a
recurring theme in my course.
Because we use genre
in American society.
I think all cultures
do this, but we've
made particularly rich
and cunning use of genre
in American society.
In many media, but
especially in film.
And if you look at
particular long live genre,
like the Western, or
the detective story,
or the domestic melodrama,
over time what you of course
can recognize are changing
cultural and social attitudes.
So, the Western
has become a screen
on which America's anxieties
about the Vietnam War
have been projected.
Why would the Western
work so well for this?
One answer is what
I've been saying
all along about
the power of genre,
and the power of repetition.
Look if a thing is
repeated again, and again,
and again, it looks familiar.
When it's so familiar,
what happens?
It licenses something
disturbing Because the genre,
it seems on the surface, to
contain so many familiar,
reassuring elements, those
very elements of reassurance
enable the exploration of
disturbing, or uncertain,
or problematic materials.
And of course, because--
not any one of these films
would have nothing
like the power
they actually have if
they existed individually.
But it's because they're part
of this long conversation that
goes back to the
earliest days of movies,
that they have the
power that they have.
One of the functions of genre
is one of the deep subjects
of my course.
And I want students to see
how centrally variations
in genre forms can reflect
social and historical
realities.
And you can feel
this in every film.
You can feel this in
every television program.
If you look at American
television from the 1950s
to the 1990s, let's say
you've restricted yourself
to situation comedy, what
do you think you would see?
You would see a drama in which
the American family undergoes
profound change.
What happens?
Women become more important.
Patriarchal values become
less, and less powerful.
Children become
more respected-- are
treated less like
appendages to the family.
And in some-- by
the '80s and '90s,
sometimes the children have more
dominant roles than the adults,
and are often even shown to
be wiser than their parents.
Right?
Something that would
have been impossible
in the early 1950s, a
more patriarchal era,
when the classic television
program about families
was called, Father Knows Best.
Another spine question,
or organizing key question
in the course, is
deeply literary for me.
In other words, what
I try to do here,
is encourage the
students to develop what
I'll call an aesthetic sense.
To begin to have
confidence when they say,
that's a good film,
or that's a bad film.
I think that's a good movie.
I think that's a bad movie.
I think that's a
good-- and what I
try to tell them is that
that judgment, good or bad,
isn't merely subjective.
It isn't just what
you feel, right?
That there may be potentially
objective standards,
by which we can judge
the excellence of texts.
Part of it may
remain subjective,
but we can still judge
excellence when we see acting.
We can judge
excellence when we ask
how well the film is edited.
We can judge the excellence of
various aspects of the film.
And teaching students
how to do that,
and to distinguish between
effective and ineffective uses
of the medium, turns out
to be not simply a skill
that you give to students
who are watching movies,
it's a skill you can give to
students who read poems, who
read books, who go to plays.
So one of the
central principles I
try to teach them about this,
how they can distinguish what
I call a work of art from
a mere entertainment,
is what I call the
multiplicity principle.
And what I mean by the
multiplicity principle
is fairly clear.
And I give many
examples in the course.
Essentially, it's
the idea that what
happens in a particular moment
will have multiple functions.
You won't just look
at the scene in order
to have the plot extended.
The scene will also
dramatize character.
It will also tell you
something about the atmosphere
in which the character lives.
Do you remember the
moment in the passage
I showed you, from the De
Sica movie, Umberto D.?
That very brief moment, where we
see a man get on a tram, a bus,
and sit next to someone on
the bus and the bus moves.
It's a completely
wordless sequence.
And there's a
character we've never
seen in the field
before, who sits
down next to the protagonist.
No words exchanged.
When our protagonist gets
up, and gets off the bus,
the camera lingers briefly
on the man he left behind.
And we see that
men go like this.
And what I suggested
to you, again,
I suggested that this
was a moment of richness
and complexity of
multiplicity, in a way,
because one implication
of that scene
was that the man, this stranger
that we'll never meet again,
that we only saw for
one brief instant
in the course of the film, might
have concealed a story as deep,
as rich, and as moving, as
that of our hero, Humberto D.
When a text contains-- when a
moment contains multiplicity,
when it many things
simultaneously,
you're in the presence
of a kind of excellence.
That's only one principle, but
it's a very valuable principle.
And you can see it's
worth if you compare,
let's say, a trivial
or relatively banal
form of action entertainment,
on the one hand,
with a movie that has
complex characters in it.
And you could see the
different kinds of demands.
Or, even that a serious
action adventure film,
a film that incorporates action
adventure elements in it,
but also has a serious subject
matter, to ones that don't.
Let's say, Kurosawa's
samurai movies,
against the trivial,
merely entertaining samurai
movies that weren't interested
in history or character.
What you try to do
is give the students
a greater and
greater sensitivity,
not just to the particular text
that exhibits such excellence,
but you want to arm them, so
that when they encounter things
on their own, they'll be
able to make this judgment.
A second aspect of
this excellence,
what I call artistic quality,
is the quality of organic form.
I talk about this again,
and again in the course,
and try to show them
instances of it.
At its simplest level,
the term, of course,
derives from Coleridge,
who borrowed it
from the German romantics.
But essentially, it's
the idea that every text
should generate a form that
is unique to its needs.
Form should be--
in other words, you
should not have a
prior form into which
content is poured, right?
The form of the text,
the shape of the text,
should take it nature from
the meaning of the text.
From what the text is saying.
And if you think about the
structure of modern times,
you'll see that it's a
marvelously distilled
instance-- a marvelously clear
instance of the principle
of organic form.
What happens to Charlie
serially is more meaningful,
in a way, than what happens
to him in a single episode.
And the fact that this-- that
we have this sense that things
are repeating, that
Charlie is on a treadmill,
that he lives a cyclical life,
that he'll always have moments
of hope and hopelessness, that
he'll have momentary times when
he's free of-- when he
finds a place to live,
or finds sufficient food,
but that it will always
be temporary.
That his life is
always on the road.
always in process.
And, that at the
same time, he never
lets himself completely despair.
There's always a moment where
his resilience reasserts
itself.
Well, those elements are
embedded, in some sense,
in the very structure, the
very organization, of the film.
There should be a symbiotic
relationship, a marriage,
a linkage, between
form and content.
Between the way, the
shape of the text.
Between the strategies
and techniques
that are used to embody the
story, and what the story says.
There should be a marriage
between form and content.
That's what organic form is.
If you can show students
moments of organic form,
and if they can
really recognize it,
they are proofed for
life against banal art.